what's going on guys this is rob and
just some updates for you guys just
wanted to give you guys some heads up um
yes we will have a Marvel request Monday
video coming out later on today they'll
be coming out at around 6pm or so and
there's a few things that I want to
address here in this video but the first
thing I want to talk to you guys about
is is the weekly pulled on net as you
guys know we've been really working on
getting this website launched and
Tiffany and Danielle have been awesome
and the work that they've been putting
in and so the website is officially live
now so you can go to the weekly pool Ned
you can see the articles that's some of
your fellow commenters and some of your
fellow I guess subscribers here on my
youtube channel and I'm Betty's youtube
channel and Sal's youtube channel are
offering with regards to what they think
about various things taking place we
have the form the weekly board which is
a place for you guys to just talk with
us right now we have forms dedicated to
us as youtubers and we have a general
chat we also have an announcement swear
Tiffany and Danielle will keep you guys
abreast of any changes that are going on
with the website what will happen as
time progresses least what we're
shooting for at the moment is that as
the forum grows will add more things to
it then of course a lot of this is a
combination of input from you guys as
well as the direction that we want to
take the form in so check out the check
out both of them I'll have links down in
the description for both and I'll put
off what links to the description or I
guess in the in the video in the
comments section there we go for you
guys to click on and and i'll have to i
just have to make sure that i uncheck it
as spam because youtube will mark you as
spam even if you're the person that
makes a video I don't understand why
YouTube your comment system has problems
it needs to be re Jared so anyway um a
couple things that I wanted to address
in this video in addition to that the
first thing is we that is to say I need
to get back to our roots you know when I
initially started this whole Marvel
explain thing when I was sitting at home
and I said I wonder what would happen if
I explained jason wyngarde like that was
the whole thing that I undertook like
explaining stuff and I think somewhere
along the line it moved away from comets
explained to like comics rent to you
like I guess it's a changing YouTube
world like youtube com / comics read to
you because that's what we turn into
when I turn this channel into is hey
guys here's the death of bull brain and
here's page by page everything that
happens the death of Wolverine initially
it had to be like for me it was based on
the significance of a story it wasn't
based on what was going on in the story
the death of Wolverine is about
Wolverine having a contract put out on
him he loses healing factor he tries to
find out who the contract is he meets
Viper ultimately it turns out it's dr.
Abraham and then he kills dr. Abraham
and then he's covered in Anna man to him
and he dies in the sunset done and done
that's it that's all that happens I mean
for me it's the significance of the
story this mom will killing off when
they're longest-standing characters in
the history of comics there's Marvel
acknowledging the fact that it was time
for Wolverine to go away now Wolverine
will come back I think we all know that
but for me was initially the
significance of these events the the
importance I guess of what it is I don't
know of what it is it made these things
relevant of what it doesn't made these
stories signals of what it does it made
the story significant um but take your
secret wars for example the secret Wars
was a significant story for several
reasons so what we'll do a video about
secret wars but secret Wars was
significant for several reasons one
because it introduced the Venom symbiote
to the Marvel Universe to because of dr.
doom dr. doom took on the power of the
beyond her when dr. dupe said on the
power of the honored turned singer Wars
you moved away from this villain who was
the quintessential foe of the Fantastic
Four and a villain for a handful of
other characters I'm offer was like look
you know no one rustles the jimmies of
Doctor Doom that's basically what they
were saying you know this guy will go to
any lengths in order to achieve his goal
you know one of the other significant
things was the beyond we saw the super
omnipotent God like being introduced and
fans love to be on there they were like
oh my god the beyond her but you got to
explain to be on her like you you know
Marvel tell us what the deals with
beyond her and that gave us sycamores
part two and then it gave us the
Illuminati retcon I don't know why and
was done but nonetheless you know there
are very significant moments in that
event and I think there's somewhere
along the line I stopped focusing on the
significance of the story and just said
here's the story like go check it out
and that's that's not what this channel
is based on and that's not what this
channel needs to be this channel needs
to be comics explained what's the
significance of the killing joke that
should have been one video The Killing
junction of in one video and it should
have been here's a significance of the
killing joke this is why the killing
joke is important and so we're going to
get back to that we need to get back to
those roots of explaining the
significance of a story why should you
be reading Secret Wars if you're going
to be getting into the Marvel 2015
summer event the secret wars in 2015 by
Jonathan Hickman why should you be
reading future imperfect why should you
know about x-men the animated series why
do you need to know about spider-man
annual number 21 i think and spider-man
one more day how does that tie into
spider-man renew your vows which is
what's going to be taking place in the
summer event these are things that I
need to get back into these are things
that I need to get sorted back into and
so other thing about never quite some
time you know and and and yeah so that's
just the way things go as far as videos
go videos are going to be shorter that's
not up for debate I'm not looking for
opinions that's just the way things are
going to be but nonetheless you know I'm
yeah that's it that's pretty much it I
had this whole speech like done you know
I had this whole speech like okay like
I'm gonna say this this listen this and
I'd like the script memorized and I was
like you know what let's just you from
the hip let's just see where it goes and
I think you know I I'm Ron Burgundy I
think we did pretty good so far I think
we're okay but um but anyway so you know
I love just kind of like talking to you
guys like there's no real I don't know
I'm gonna stop along behind where that
being said I'm gonna go and bring this
video to an end and I'll catch you guys
letting please
be sure to follow me on twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly